leute wacht karneval in köln und warum
kann ich nicht tun in der form wie es
sonst machen können dass dieses jahr
einfach sticht ich mache ist viel zu
gefährlich wir müssten so was bei der
ereignisse erwarten wohl nicht sein kann
weil muss hinnerk es tut mir leid also
ich wünschte wir könnten etwas anderes
sagen aber es wird dieses jahr nicht
gehen und dafür werden die karnevalisten
auch verständnis haben
die haben mich nicht ich gleich jetzt an
nein ich glaube nicht dass es circa das
kann nicht stattfinden
[Musik]
so herr lauterbach jetzt reden über
karneval gerne gesundheit ist ja schön
und gut aber was ist mit meinem recht an
weiberfastnacht in die innenstadt zu
kürzen
das ist ein recht was ich nie groß
bestand aber also wie gesagt ich hatte
also dann wäre es auch noch neben der
erosion übertragung eine übertragung
durch kontaminierte flüssigkeit
möglicherweise wird es nicht besser
machen
ich freue mich das casal arretiert ich
sage nach wie vor karneval muss
stattfinden
ihr seid doch der gleichen meinung oder
karneval preise kann man ja nicht
verbieten hat ist wie weihnachten glaube
ich aber so wie wir das kennen ist
natürlich sinnlos dieses jahr das
wirklich funktioniert planungssicherheit
das wäre schon ganz cool mit mir hätte
die planungssicherheit ich der kämpfer
für den karneval rufe zur spontanen
großdemonstration auf
naja
carla ist schon geil es ist alarmstufe
rot man will den karneval absagen sie
müssen ja nichts trinken
ich versuche nur den karneval zu retten
aber kamelle mitnehmen oder was es ist
schwierig wird es schwerer ohne pfützen
und ich weiß ja aber man muss ja auch
als rentensystem denken wenn jetzt hier
nicht geputzt wird dann kommt ja gar
keinen nachschub mehr 1 ja aber da ist
es sowieso zu spät ich weiß ja ich
wusste wir ein paar luftballons auf
nachdem es schön drehen sie zur musik
und dann habe ich meinen plan sein kann
dann ganz köln auch zu ihnen nach hause
kommen nein absolut nicht
heute fährt die 18 bis ins krankenhaus
krank
ich werde karnevalssonntag 60 so hat
mache ich denn da also meine was sonntag
schwarz zu gucken
herr sparen helfen sie mir in meinen
ersten geburtstag zu retten
was halten sie von diesem hygiene
konzepte schunkeln so mit abstand können
wir zusammen schon probiert er ja nicht
so eine hübsche frau weber ja da kann
ich verstehen aber ich habe schon alles
getan
ja leider anfang zu stellen
also ehrlich gesagt ich bin hier schon
lange dafür ist der kanal nur noch alle
drei bis vier jahre statt finde ich viel
besser ein sehr lustiger ja dann ziehen
sie noch irgendwo anders sind in
chemnitz große kriege also gegen köln
schloss ist nicht hier bestechen oder ja
wie viel liter kölsch töten so ein virus
ab aber kannst sagen so und ich sechs
liter aber dann stirbt der mensch mit
dem virus und der wenn der wirt stirbt
dann im wahrsten sinne des wortes
tochter
[Musik]
was die über meinen arsch geigensolo war
doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]